♫ ♫
>> Laura: IT’S TIME FOR OUR
SEEN AND UNSEEN SEGMENTS WHERE
WE EXPOSE WHAT’S REALLY BEHIND
THE BIG CULTURE STORIES OF THE
DAY.
WE BEGIN WITH ONE OF THE BIGGEST
BATTLES IN THE CULTURE WARS, IT
HAS BEEN FOR 40 PLUS YEARS AND
SOMETHING THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP
IS DOING THAT NO SAVING
PRESIDENT HAS DONE BEFORE.
LET’S BRING IN FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR RAYMOND ARROYO.
WHAT IS HE DOING FOR THE FIRST
TIME IN HISTORY?
>> THIS IS A BIG DEAL.
TOMORROW BEFORE THEY PRO-LIFE
MARCH, THE PRESIDENT HAS NEVER
ADDRESSED A MARCH FOR LIFE.
THIS PRESIDENT IS HAVING A ROSE
GARDEN CEREMONY WITH ORGANIZERS
OF THE MARCH AS WELL AS YOUNG
KIDS FROM COLLEGES ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
IT WILL BE SIMULCAST,
RONALD REAGAN DID A PHONE CALL
THAT WAS SIMULCAST BUT THIS IS
THE FIRST PRESIDENT THAT WILL
ACTUALLY BE THERE.
>> Laura: A LOT OF PEOPLE
THOUGHT AND PREDICTED HE WAS
JUST SAYING HE WAS PRO-LIFE,
REMEMBER THAT FAMOUS EXCHANGE
DURING THE BAIT, HE SAID THIS  E
ARE BABIES.
>> THE MOST PROBE LIFE
ANNOUNCEMENT.
>> Laura: REAGAN DID A PHONE
CALL, BUSH SENT A LETTER.
>> HE DID A RECORDED SPEECH.
THERE IS SUBSTANCE THE PRESIDENT
IS FOLLOWING IT UP WITH.
TODAY HE ESTABLISHED AT THE
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
DEPARTMENT A CONSCIENCE AND
RELIGIOUS LIBERTY PROTECTION
UNIT THAT WOULD ALLOW
HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS,
INSTITUTIONS AND DOCTORS TO OPT
OUT OF ABORTIONS AND GENDER
REASSIGNMENT SURGERY.
HIGHLY CONTROVERSIAL BUT A
DEFENSE OF RELIGIOUS LIBERTY
THAT WAS ROLLED BACK UNDER
PRESIDENT OBAMA.
>> Laura: GENDER REASSIGNMENT
SURGERY AND THAT’S WHAT OUR KIDS
ARE NEEDING TODAY.
HOW DO WE GO FROM THAT TO
LAUNDRY PODS?
THE PODS FREIGHT MADE.
>> KIDS HAVE BEGUN TO EAT THESE
AS A CHALLENGE ONLINE.
YOU COULDN’T GET KIDS TO PUT
SOAP IN THEIR MOUTHS WITHOUT A
PUNISHMENT.
NOW AN ONLINE CHALLENGE, THEY
ARE COOKING THEM, THEY EAT THEM.
FIVE PEOPLE HAVE DIED OVER THIS.
IF THEY VOMIT THEY GET SICK.
IT HAS CAUSED BLINDNESS.
IF IT’S PRETTY, PEOPLE ARE DRAWN
TO IT.
THEY CRAVE IT BECAUSE IT LOOKS
LIKE A CANDY.
LIKE SO MANY THINGS IN THE
CULTURE, YOU WILL BE ATTRACTED
AND DO THINGS THEY SHOULDN’T DO.
>> Laura: DUMB STUNTS ONLINE,
WE HAVE SEEN THIS.
>> 10,000 COMPLAINTS A YEAR TO
THE CENTERS OF DISEASE CONTROL.
>> Laura: THEY WILL BE
STARTING THE POWDER.
WHAT ABOUT THE #HeToo MOVEMENT
MOVEMENT?
>> WERE MEMBER THE NAKED YOUNG
KIDS AND ALL THE TEENS, HE
SHOULD 15 MALE MODELS CAME
FORWARD AND SAID I WAS ABUSED BY
THIS GUY AND I WANT TO GO
THROUGH ALL THE GROSS DETAILS.
IT IS AN INTERESTING QUESTION,
YOU HAVE MEN WHO ARE SEXUALLY
ABUSE, THEY ARE PAID ABOUT 100
TIMES, 200 TIMES LESS THAN THEIR
FEMALE COUNTERPARTS.
>> Laura: IT SHOULD THERE BE
EQUALITY?
>> MAYBE IT’S TIME FOR A
#HeToo MOVEMENT.
>> Laura: THE PRO-LIFE MARCH
WILL BE BIG TOMORROW.
>> I HOPE THEY DON’T LOOK LIKE
THE GOLDEN GLOBE LADIES WE SAW.
>> Laura: DO WE HAVE THAT FULL
SCREEN OF THE GOLDEN GLOBE GALS?
>> THIS IS A LITTLE BIT LIKE THE
LAUNDRY POND STORY, PEOPLE SEE
ONE THING AND THEY ARE DRAWN TO
IT.
BUT IF YOU ARE SAYING RESPECT
WOMEN --
THIS MAY NOT BE THE IMAGE YOU
WANT TO PORTRAY.
I’M ALL FOR BEAUTIFUL WOMEN BUT
DO YOU WANT TO BE RESPECTED FOR
YOUR MIND AND YOUR WORK OR FOR
OTHER ASPECTS?
>> Laura: ALWAYS FOR THE MIND.